Hello.
Welcome to our stage.
Just want to show you
Bingo there.
Our Art Department recreated
these real apartments
that we shot in initially.
Check this freaking
apartment wall out.
You know in Seinfeld
they were like,
"Look at our clean apartments."
Or whatever.
It's like nothing like New York.
This is like New Yorkers
made this apartment.
When we shot on location
they found these two doors
next to each other
and one was normal.
And one was like
a sticker collage.
That would be Ilana's.
And then when that dirty asshole
got elected it became
all activist stickers.
Which is sad,
but funny and informative.
It's Angelique Clark everybody.
Hello.
Yes. I love these wig heads.
They're so funny, Ilana's wigs.
Cracks me up because this like
reminds me when I was twelve.
You better believe
I have a metal weed box.
So some cool PA found these.
These are made out
of old plastic bags.
And also our PA made these,
these plant holders
out of like plastic bags.
Just like Thank You bags, right?
Yeah.
It's fun when we have
real pictures.
We took this at like the season
one wrap party I think.
Arturo Castro and Abbi,
who plays Abbi and me.
And that's real.
Oh my god, maybe I'll take this.
Yeah. You should take it.
Today's
our last day on set.
And it's going to truly
go away forever.
It cracks me up.
I've never seen on TV
a more disgusting bathroom.
I mean absolutely grotesque.
Yeah, it's pretty gross.
It's pretty fucking gross.
Okay. So let's show you my room.
It's funny, it's like
forced processing.
I'll just take
this off a second.
I still need to get
the pictures after.
In the web series,
Abbi made this cardboard trumpet
for some weird thing
we did out of tampon boxes
and then it was recreated
for the show.
These I had hanging in my room.
These boobs ...
oh it was from a fucking
sketch show I did at UCB.
To mature the tits on the wall,
we framed them.
This is Ilana's work station.
She is a professional now.
Since you're like
an eco warrior,
these are all made
from milk cartons,
you know,
recycled water bottles
and of course you have
your condoms
and your tampons
and your vampire teeth.
The credit goes to us
but it's John Cox and Angelique
Clark and Jess Petriselli
but it's also like literally
like a dozen queer
young people of color
who are really
the new Broad City
who are actually
executing this shit.
The fucking clothes
organization cracks me up.
It's like so organized
and this is my real life
of like being visual.
This is weird because this like
used to be my sweater
but it's like....
I felt like I had to give it
to you for your room.
It's so funny. It's so funny.
The show ending is like,
it's ending for all of us.
It's not just me and Abbi.
We've been doing the project
since 2009.
It's good to keep
moving forward.
With every ending
there's a new beginning.
I can't get enough of that.
Well, damn.